[Music]
hey
ladies and gentlemen time for another
christmas
week matinee we've been watching
christmas movies all [ __ ] week long
actually
the last two weeks yeah you said ladies
and gentlemen ladies and gentlemen like
it's a damn television program it is
back in the 50s ladies and gentlemen
this was pretty good this [ __ ] here i
had to restart that yeah this one was a
pretty good one
imagine if like uh if the thing
was a christmas movie and with also kind
of like a black comedy
yeah element but it's very very dry
comedy okay so this is rare exports a
christmas tale
this is a finnish movie came out way
back in 2010
um somehow because i think somebody said
earlier that um they thought we had
covered this one already and i thought
we had two
but then when i was watching it i was
like because it keeps it comes up on
like pretty much every
you know best christmas horror movies
list so i'm like
i thought i had seen it but then when i
was watching it when i was watching it
last night i'm like yeah i don't think i
did see this
actually yeah i don't know why because i
guess i heard so much about it that i
thought i had seen it
but yeah so this movie is like 10 years
old and i was only just now getting
around to seeing it
and i have to say that this was pretty
delightful
i really really love the idea of it and
now here's something that i didn't know
until
after i watched it and i was starting to
do research into it
so the thing where the idea for this
movie came from
is in 2003 uh the guys that made
this uh their names are jail mari
hellander and
jusso hilander and they made a short
film
back in 2003 that was called rare
exports inc
and it was about and it's on vimeo i
think it's also on youtube too because i
watched it earlier today
and it's basically about these three
guys
one's a tracker and one's like a sniper
and all this other stuff
and their job is they go and hunt wild
santa clauses
in lapland and then ship them out
you know they train them and then they
ship they train them to be mall santas
and then they ship them out like all
over the world
and it's done very very seriously like
it's this very
um this very weighty thing that they're
doing like in lapland and it's like it's
passed on from father to son and all of
a sudden
it's like hilarious so they made it
yeah it's like i said it's a short film
it's only like seven eight minutes long
and then um it was so successful online
like it went viral
so then they made another one in 2005
called rare exports the official safety
instructions
and this one shows what happens when
when you don't care like when you don't
follow all the rules that you're
supposed to follow when you have one of
these wild santa clauses
in custody and um it's pretty funny
because it's like pretty gory like
it goes into this into the movie as well
where you're not supposed to swear
around them you're not supposed to drink
around them you're supposed to smoke
around them or they get like really
really
aggressive and they'll like tear your
face off so basically this movie is like
showing you everything you shouldn't do
so they have like this one guy like in
all this [ __ ] padding and everything
like that like smoking and swearing at
the guy and then like the santa like
flying out like
getting the [ __ ] out of him and it's
like super super funny and then like at
the end
they end up having to like put one of
the santa clauses down
because because he was like because he
went like they're like once he smells
like human blood like
he can't like train him so it's like
it's a [ __ ] brilliant idea
i don't know if i would i'm kind of glad
that i saw the movie first
and then saw the short films even though
the short films came out prior to it
because i think because when you're
watching the movie
you don't really get into the whole
shipping santa's out like that's
really not until the end you know what i
mean um
because pretty much the whole you know
premise of the movie
is that there's this team
and he's like americans and british
people and there's one guy who's like an
archaeologist i guess
and he's clearly supposed to be bellock
from uh
indiana jones i mean i'm pretty sure
that that's who i battled that after
but and especially because the the end
scene of the movie is also very indiana
jones-esque
so he's digging in this mountain which
is called corva tenturi
in lapland and he discovers that this
huge mountain was actually the grave of
santa claus
like that he's frozen in a huge block of
ice so
they basically extract him and then like
there's this little reindeer farm that's
like right near it
and the two and the two little kids that
are like spying on it and
the one little kid piatari who's kind of
like the main character
he um he believes that santa claus like
he
goes into he has all these books about
santa claus and basically what they're
doing is they're doing the
uh the sami people where they have that
uh
you know myth about santa claus how it's
based on the yule goat
you know what i mean yeah the joe lapuki
or whatever they call it
um that's what this dude is he but you
can't really see him that well in the
movie because he's like frozen in a
block of ice but he looks like
kind of like a big santa claus but also
kind of like a krampus yeah you never
really get to see him like he has like
big huge goat horns and he's like
he's a really really huge that's the
only thing i didn't really like about
the movies that he didn't actually get
to see the santa claus
yeah and it's not you know the kids
plainly
say that it's not the coca-cola santa
claus that's that's the fake [ __ ]
yeah all right what we know of it the
coca-cola santa claus is kind of based
on the elves the elves look like santa
claus it's got old dudes with beards
yeah there's like naked old men looking
around
that's where the elves look and i guess
the way santa claus really looks is i
think it
probably just looks like that like a
krampus yeah
something big with horns it's huge
because you yeah because you could kind
of see him and like i said you could see
the drawings like in the books that the
kid had so you're just assuming that
that's probably what
what the creature looked like um but
because you don't really see it until
the end and it's still
partly frozen in the ice you can see
it's big horn sticking out you can kind
of see the
outline of it like in the block but it
never gets
completely thought out yeah i think i
was kind of disappointed i wanted to see
it
yeah i think one thing that a lot of
people like i don't really hear a lot of
complaints about this movie because a
lot of people really liked it
um but the one complaint that i heard on
a couple of the things was that they
wish there had been more horror in it
like they
because they do show stuff like um you
know they catch one of the elves
which like i said it's like a naked old
man that they think is santa claus
they catch him in a wolf trap and they
think he's dead because he had like
spikes and [ __ ] through him and
everything
but then like they take him in and
they're gonna cut him up because like
the main guy
who's the dad of the kid piatari
is like a reindeer you know they they
kill reindeer and cut him up and sell
them for meat
and uh so he's gonna cut up this old man
and
turns out the old man is still alive and
he when he smells children he starts
getting all agitated
and then one of the guys like tries to
like is [ __ ] with him like with
gingerbread and everything because i
guess they're attracted to gingerbread
also which i thought was very funny
and then like it bites that guy's ear
off but you can see like the elves
the elves like kill people but it's a
lot of it's like off screen
like you'll kind of hear something and
then like all hard hats will come like
flying into the [ __ ]
so it's not like real bloody or gory
but i will say that people that kind of
complained about that
once once i went back and watched the
short films
those are a lot more gory those are like
a lot bloodier
a lot of homages to uh to the thing in
this this is very much like the thing
except
kind of funny you're right you know what
i mean and like the and i love
i mean this is probably one of the best
um ideas for a movie you know what i
mean like the most creative
particularly a christmas movie taking
place in the snow
um it's a group of uh finnish hunters
and uh they all kind of look like
crustals crustals
and and keith davis it's a gang of tea
brussels
deep in the honky motherland and it's
just
uh they got their sons are with them
they're hunting deer they got guns
and snowmobiles and uh they're just
trying to figure out what killed the
deer
and the the kids know it's a santa claus
it's not the santa claus we know but
yeah it's not the santa claus because
they don't find out until later that the
little old man
it's a monster they're yeah they don't
know that's like the actual santa claus
they don't see him till the end
but i think one of the best things about
this other than the idea which i love
the [ __ ]
idea of because i mean basically what
they do
at the end like when they get rid of the
of the big huge monster
you know the the krampus thing or
whatever it is that you'll i guess it's
based on the yule goat
um which is like a dude with goat feet
which is kind of like a krampus yeah but
they showed his feet and had feet like a
like a the members human's them living
huge footprints no that was the elves
that
was that that was yeah yeah because the
elves just looked like regular like
naked old men
that's right because this thing never
thought out that thing never thought out
that's what they were doing because
remember like at some point during the
movie like everybody's like
why did all my potato sacks get stolen
why did all of our
heaters like somebody broke in and stole
all of our heaters out of our houses
like tore
the radiators out of the walls and [ __ ]
like that it's because they put them all
they had this hanger and they were like
trying to thaw them out
they had all the kids and sacks yeah
okay he was gonna eat them yeah
it was funny [ __ ] it was pretty funny
like i said it's like it was a really
really good
idea and they really um what ends up
happening is like after they get rid of
like the big monster
um they decide because all of the
reindeer because the elves killed all of
the reindeer and ate them
so obviously they don't they lost like
all this money because that's like their
only source of income
was this reindeer meat so they decide
what they're gonna do
is they're gonna start this company um
and they're gonna start shipping these
santas out like
to to malls and stuff but the funny
thing is that they have to train them
because these are essentially like wild
i mean they're old dudes but they're
like wild animals yeah they don't talk
like they can't talk and they can't
they'll just like eat your face if you
like make them mad
so they have to like so they have like
this big long thing at the end where
they have them all they put like little
dolls in their laps and like
the things try to eat them they're like
no they're like they're like hitting
them
and stuff it's kind of cool yeah and
it's like like i said if you see the
short films
the first two short films the first um
short film which was
uh rare exports incorporated basically
is like as though that company was real
and had made
like um not necessarily a commercial but
they were like telling you like how the
company worked
so they had the thing about the three
guys and it looked like the three guys
that were in the movie
like i don't know if it was or if they
just had dudes that looked like really
similar but it looked like the same
actors
so they had them like going out and you
know darting
like this fat old guy that was like
running through the tundra or whatever
they had to keep like
they had to keep darting them like to
put it to sleep and then
um they take him back to the thing and
he's like
you know they have to hose them all down
and everything and then like
they strap him in a chair and he's like
misbehaving and they like keep whacking
him with a stick
until he's like doing [ __ ] that he's
supposed to yeah the funny thing about
it you know
these guys are these guys are real kind
of serious [ __ ] macho [ __ ]
you know rednecks of the north
[Laughter]
and they're they're doing this [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] trying to train these elves
and they're like totally serious about
it
just dead that's what makes this movie
so funny
they tried to actually get they they
felt that
they felt that these these elves owed
them
85 000 yeah because they ate all their
reindeer
they ate all the reindeer so when they
first find one they try to get money out
of it it's just like
you know yeah like we have santa claus
and they were like holding him for
ransom
yeah he didn't have any clothes on so i
don't even know what what
you know how is he going to have any
money
dude doesn't talk and did you have
clothes well no they were trying to
ransom him to
the um the archaeological team yeah
when they first met him he says where's
our money yeah remember that we want our
money
but like i said i think that's what
makes this movie so that's what made it
so funny to me
is that it was like deadpan serious
like i like that they it's not even
though the premise of it sounds
insane like it doesn't come across as
wacky or zany or anything like that it's
played like very very
straight which i think makes it funnier
i mean to me like makes it funnier
and i will say that i really love the
the little main little
boy piatari that kid was like adorable
and also i guess they don't really go a
lot into it but i guess his dad
um is kind of like i don't know if their
mom's dead or something like that it
does seem like a couple conversations
they had it seemed like their mom had
just died and it was like the first
christmas without her or something like
that
but they don't go supe super into it
because you know these guys that are in
this movie are like super super stoic
and it's like they don't talk about
their feelings or any
girly [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean they're just kind of like it's an
all-male cast yeah it's like there
there's no i don't think there's no
women in this movie is there i don't
know there's a lot of stuff that was
was from the thing yeah it's an all-male
cast there was kind of like a crustal
keith david dynamic going on between two
leads uh except they had their kids with
them
yes i think at least one of them has
kids but i don't remember the other one
the other guy had a kid too yeah
the other kid's name was uh juso i think
yeah
that was like the other one they found
where they started his friend they found
where they [ __ ] cut the
santa out of the ice it was like the
scene where uh
where where uh mccready and and and and
the guys
found the place where the the blow where
the black and white black eyes
yeah yeah yeah so and it's definitely an
homage yeah
and a lot of the kind of stuff they were
wearing
was kind of from kind of from the thing
yeah it was very similar which like i
said
you know yeah you could say because it's
in a similar climate but i think they
were
they were very deliberately trying to
see they were going like yeah they dug
it up out of the ice the damn americans
well yeah in in the uh in the thin
thing it was the finish was going yeah
yeah the swedes they brought whoever it
was they weren't the swedes
[Laughter]
they were playing that they were they
were doing that kind of thing they dug
it up out of the ice
and it's pissed off yeah so they
like i said they definitely did that and
there was a little bit of an homage to
um
a couple homages to uh indiana jones uh
as well
uh uh you know raider's a lost ark
rather
but the thing that's cool about it is
that so the little kid
you can tell the dad is kind of like i
don't know if he's necessarily
disappointed
in the kid but he's just always kind of
like as [ __ ] kid
that he's like stuck with so he's trying
to get the kid to like you know learn to
heard the reindeer and the kids like
falling over and stuff and so he's just
kind of like
you know kind of thing so i think it's
kind of cool that like this little kid
piatari he's the only one that knows
that that's
that it's a santa claus that they dug
out and he's getting like really he's
freaking out about it because he's read
all the [ __ ] about like the big giant
monster santa claus and he's
pretty sure that that's what's coming
like he figures out all the clues and
everything
and then like he has this great arc
where
at the end because he's been kind of
like not necessarily [ __ ] on by his dad
but his dad's just kind of like
just thinks of him as a nuisance or like
he's not or he's hopeless or whatever
and so like when he discovers the big
monster in the end
and you know all the kids in sacks like
at the [ __ ] foot of it and the ice is
melting and everything
the kid just he just like drops his
balls and he just kind of like becomes
the hero and he has a plan
and he's like this is what we're gonna
do we're gonna do this then the other
thing and then he's riding around on
this [ __ ]
he's trying to sling load the kids they
slip the kids out of the helicopter and
then the kid gets up on the net
and he's talking in the walkie-talkie
telling everybody what to do and [ __ ]
like that
that like [ __ ] cracked me up so much
that little boy just like up there
telling everybody what to do
and everybody was totally doing it too
they're like you know yes sir
what's in all this other kind of crap it
was [ __ ] hilarious but yeah so
if you haven't seen this movie like i
said it's 10 years old um
yeah it doesn't look like it though it
looks like it's made yesterday yeah it
really does it looks i mean the
cinematography is really really nice as
well
and um and i think it helps too that
they didn't use
oh you know they didn't use any cgi or
anything like that that i could see
yeah the sling load scene and all yeah i
guess that was cg and the hordes of
elves and but it didn't but it looked
pretty good yeah it looked pretty good
and the santa was cg but you know you
couldn't really
you know the frozen santa yeah
yeah it wasn't bad it didn't stand out
to me it's like being
oh it was like so 10 years ago yeah um
but yeah
so you wouldn't know that it was like
that old and i was actually surprised
when i looked it up because i've been
hearing about it for so long that i was
like finally got around to seeing it
and i couldn't believe it was that old
but i would i don't know if it's better
to watch the short films before you see
this
or i don't really know i just see the
movie i didn't see the show i think well
yeah but i mean
if you see the movie and then you see
the short films which is what i did
i think it really like deepens your
appreciation for the movie so maybe see
the short film second
because you know like i said the short
films are more concerned with like the
company that they made
like after like after the events of the
movie i guess
so maybe it actually even though the
short films were made before this
movie maybe it would be better to see
the short films after because that's
kind of like
now we have this company started and
this is how we do it like this is how we
train the santas and stuff
and um so i think maybe in the timeline
that's probably a better way to look
to do it and plus the [ __ ] short
films are hilarious
and um i think i've watched them on
vimeo but somebody said that they were
on youtube as well
i'm sure they're on there somewhere
because they were like actually pretty
popular back in the day
um so yeah if you want you know if you
haven't seen this it's like a really
really fun
uh finished christmas movie and uh it's
just
it's such a great idea i just love the
concept of it
and it's like really creative and it's
on
shutter but i think it's also on
tubie so if you don't have shutter then
you can watch it for free with
commercials
on to be if you would like to do that so
uh i guess anything else you would like
to add all right so
we have a couple other christmas movies
we're gonna do this week
uh we've already watched one of them and
then i'm gonna watch another one
later like tonight or tomorrow or
whatever
so uh thanks you guys for stopping by as
always and uh we'll see you
again tomorrow bye